so there seem to be a pretty good
reception to the idea of going through
and organizing the various solicitations
for all-new all-different marvel which
starts this week and so what I want to
do here is I want to focus on the
solicitations of Deadpool and the
Avengers
so with the Avengers what Marvel is done
is split the group into three tiers
street-level global level and cosmic
level getting into this series the first
title I would suggest is all-new
all-different Avengers issue number zero
by Mark Waid designed to be a one-shot
comic similar 2.1 all-new all-different
Avengers issue number zero will contain
previews for the upcoming Avengers
titles including all-new all-different
Avengers squadron supreme a force New
Avengers Ultimates and uncanny Avengers
all-new all-different Avengers is also
written by Mark Waid and will have a
roster that includes Jane Foster Thor
Sam Wilson Captain America Iron Man Miss
Marvel Camilla Kahn the vision Miles
Morales and Nova in addition to this
according to an interview with Mark Waid
the comic will have a feels similar to
Chris Claremont one of the x-men in the
1980s with more emphasis on character
development rather than
planet-destroying events a force will
make its post Secret Wars return but
according to writer G willow Wilson the
a force comics from Secret Wars will not
be required reading to jump on board
with the new series furthermore the
lineup following the completion of the
five issue Secret Wars story will
largely remain the same with a couple
new additions whose identities are
unknown at the moment new Avengers is
written by al Ewing and we'll focus on a
younger version of the team led by
Robert decosta also known as sunspot
while Al Ewing was ambiguous on the plot
of the story his only real information
was that the series would see a new
version of advanced idea mechanics
rebranded from its villainous role
priest secret Wars - a superhero
organization in all-new all-different
marvel with the government pursuing them
for unknown reasons Ultimates is also an
Avengers title written by al Ewing with
the roster composed of Black Panther
Captain Marvel America Chavez Monica
Rambeau and Adam Brashear the blue
Marvel Ultimates will focus on a cosmic
version of the Avengers team it deals
with both Universal and multiversal
threats with the first story centering
on a battle against Galactus squadron
supreme will be written by James
Robinson and we'll focus on a roster
composed of Hyperion dr. spectrum and
others as they work to protect the
planet Earth but also take a more
antihero role which will bring them into
direct
conflict with the all-new all-different
Avengers and the related teams now
transitioning to Deadpool as Marvel's
most popular character depending on who
you talk to
Deadpool will be written by Jerry Duggan
and will see a return of the character
solo series furthermore during an
interview with Kelly Book Resources the
Jerry Duggan had stated that this comic
will see Deadpool as the most popular
superhero in the Marvel Universe for the
stories reflecting on how he copes with
this role as part of the uncanny
Avengers team which is also written by
Jerry Duggan Deadpool will appear
alongside spider-man Quicksilver Steve
Rogers the Human Torch brother voodoo
rogue and a new character named synapse
furthermore rather than focusing
strictly on non-mutant heroes uncanny
Avengers will focus on both
super-powered humans and mutants working
together for various purposes cable and
Deadpool will see the return of one of
Marvel's most popular team ups while
it's only scheduled to be a miniseries
it's also being written by Fabien azisa
who had written the original volume of
cable and Deadpool pre Secret Wars
because the first volume lasted 50
issues stretching for years I would
wager that the miniseries may at some
point turn into a regular series
assuming that it becomes as popular as
the original and finally Deadpool will
see another team up in the form of
spider-man Deadpool scheduled to be an
ongoing series rather than a miniseries
the title is being written by the
legendary team of Joe Kelly and Ed
McGuinness the two individuals who
transitioned Deadpool from a serious
character to a comedic character in 1997
with Deadpool vol 1 with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and let me know in the comments section
which one of these titles you're looking
forward to the most and I will catch you
guys later peace